you see former NFL quarterback and great
friend of the show and a lot of fun
times with Sean Salisbury and the Shawn
Salisbury show 3 to 6 p.m. on sports
talks 790 in Houston he joins us this
morning hi Sean how are you how are you
good to be on I'm just deciding what Red
Sox jersey I need to wear for tonight so
I've got to go find one of those oh
you're on the bandwagon bandwagon you
know better than this since I was about
6 I've been a Sox fan come on man I've
been all my whole life my mom was a yaz
fan so wait a minute Red Sox I'm gonna
ask I'm gonna ask the guys on the other
side have you guys Paulie
you've known Sean a long time have you
ever heard Sean Salisbury talk about the
Boston Red Sox Sean I'd love to back you
but I remember you being an LA guy I
don't remember you talking about
baseball team specifically yeah you
remember being an LA guy but not a
Dodger guy I first in flight listen man
anybody knows I'm a USC Trojan and I
like the Red Sox more than my alma mater
so this isn't dis bandwagon this is
suffering all the years you don't have
to grow up in Boston Dan to be your Sox
guy so yes the Sox may sweep this thing
keep keep a good eye on and I got to
find the Jersey to wear for tonight okay
all right favorite red sock growing up
beside from Carl Yastrzemski was Jim
Rice give me an obscure red sock
everybody points to Carlton Fisk home
run where he you know the obviously
inside the foul pole but it was the
Bernie carbo home run into The Sitter
field well they've got that got it to
that point so do not hate Bernie carbo
also played for my Cincinnati Reds all
right yeah you had a tweet last night
where you said more people I'm gonna
paraphrase more people care about high
school football in Houston then they do
the Houston Texans true made now after
last night the buzz may change but
there's an Astros hangover here Dan
because it's it's an Astros town it is
this is a town and you think Texas first
thing that comes to mind is football
yeah but this is an Astros town and now
with the struggle Dan
four and three going into last night's
game on my show yesterday just as a test
I said you know it's Halloween you'll
ask a question the day I said scariest
Halloween movie of all time and we were
talking about the Texans breaking down
and I must add two hundred calls on the
scariest Halloween movie we had one on
the Texans and they're four and three
going into a national televised game now
that's not on the fans I don't think
they trust Bill O'Brien as much as they
as they'd like to and watching Watson
get into it and they've had some ugly
wins but you're not going to find many
teams that are gonna win five games in a
row this year and they did they played
last night
I think it'll start to shift but going
into it I do don't throw a wedding or a
party on a Friday night in Texas as you
know you nobody's showing up because
they're going to high school football so
but what Watson dan makes it this is a
different cat now and he brings
excitement to it and it may start to
shift but going into the game you know
there was no buzz leading up to this
game about the Texans and maybe it'll
change if I said you could have the
future of deshaun Watson or dak Prescott
all deshaun Watson far more explosive
the difference between the two is that
Watson can carry a team like Rogers or
Brady on his back for a month like a
good hitter can when things are going
well I think that needs everything
around him to be good hence why they go
out and get a guy like Cooper to try and
ramp it up and I think that puts more
pressure on him to be successful but if
that's an easy one for me
Watson all the way he'll be an MVP in
this league before it's over I guess
define his style because he and I think
a lot of times we look at you know
african-american quarterbacks and we
talk about their athleticism he sort of
heaps plays alive he's not a runner he's
sort of a scrambler but how would you
define his style and and I think and
then just a great point I think the
people that label that is a
disrespective narrative to him because
my number one trait for him is I think
he's got through the roof football IQ
and his best trait is and you watched
him play in college you watched and play
in the NFL when the lights are the
brightest in Alabama Thursday Night
Football coming off an injury he plays
his best football so to me it's a guy
who still learned the one that his
weakness is his biggest strength is he
wants to be he's got this the hero
mentality that he's got to make every
play and as you know the great
quarterbacks at some point in time third
and four if you can't get it you throw
it out of bounds we'll kick a field goal
or punt
once he gets to that level there'll be
no stopping him his style of play is
he's not a true pocket guy but he's not
a true RPO get on the edge guy which I
like because I never want to take away
his strength but if I can corralled a
little bit saying hey Matt its second
Nate
it's the second quarter you don't need
to run through four defensive players we
need you on the field not the sideline
once he Corral's it but he's an
underrated guy from the pocket and he's
starting to learn how to throw people
open as opposed to wait until they're
open he throws the tight windows I think
this guy's special so if he's only gonna
evolve more and more as he trusts the
offensive line and gets rid of the hero
mentality if happened to make every play
Shawn Salisbury former NFL quarterback
hose to the Shawn Salisbury show 3 to 6
p.m. on sports talk 790 in Houston how
much of a difference if any does Amari
Cooper make that Cowboys offense on a
surface Dan when it was when it the
trade was first made I thought that the
the Raiders had fleeced the Cowboys and
then you start to look around at some of
the bodies that are drafted in the first
round or high picks like laQuan
Treadwell Dotson Corey Coleman you think
well is a first rounder and the 15th
18th pick later it will for that pick
for the Cowboys is that better than a
guy who was a first-round pick had two
really good seasons when he first
started out and I started to think well
maybe maybe this is a fair trade and a
good trade for both I think it'll help
Dan because Beasley is obviously their
best receiver right now the way to beat
the Cowboys is if you take Elliott away
you beat them for the most part
offensively but I think it just his
reputation he drops balls but if he can
elevate that and get back to the
explosiveness he had as a rookie it's an
upgrade there's no question now it's
gonna be up to him to what kind of
player he's gonna be but the ball has
got to stop hitting the ground when it
hits his hands but I think it's a wise
move and at first I thought now first
rounders too much but looking at it I
think the cowboy is needed to which
tells you they're trying to go all in
because the NFC East is is also wide
open because Philadelphia struggling as
well most likely to not be with their
respective teams in two years dak
Prescott Derek Carr Derek Carr it may
not even take two years you know John
just coming in and cleaning house and as
we know and I have a lot of respect for
Gruden is he falls in love and out of
love with players and quarterbacks as
much as anybody Dan he did it at Tampa
he's done it at Oakland until he got
rich Gannon and even in the broadcast
booth so
I think he gets impatient quickly and
there's such different personalities now
that doesn't mean it can't work but on
my philosophies if you're gonna clean
house and didn't clean it but if you
think that derrick karr can get you to
february then you keep him and he's got
some things to do because he hasn't
played as well as he did pre breaking
the leg but you know either i don't
think there's any quit - gonna get paid
because you got to look out there and
say well what's available free agency
until we draft Jerry's gonna pay DAC car
already got his money I would say
there's a chance that both will be in
there in there same place but if I had
to pick one and gamble it I would say
that the Raiders will move on from car
before the Cowboys move on from Prescott
you would know this as well as anybody I
was talking about these younger
quarterbacks and they come in ready to
play but you know Patrick mahomes there
were a lot of teams a lot of Scouts that
missed on him and I said you know part
of the success is where you are who you
have with you how's the line how's your
head coach how's your offensive
coordinator and then what kind of talent
do I have around me at the skilled
positions if I put Patrick mahomes in
Buffalo
what is Patrick mahomes doing in Buffalo
leaving us jaw dropping with some of his
ability but they're not the second best
or best team in the AFC and Dan you make
a great point and I firmly believe this
in half for a while there's no better
teacher / coach when you're in your
infancy of trying to learn with patience
but with aggressiveness and play calling
and what he wants to Nandi Reed he
couldn't have gone you think back when
Ben Roethlisberger went to Pittsburgh
Dan everybody was fast bill at 10th or
11th pick and here's a first rounder and
you go to a team that the cupboards not
bare and he got to go on with a good
team and it could have changed the
course of his career look at Archie
Manning great career always on bad teams
Ben goes to his good team same with
mahomes and and he got to a team that's
got incredible weapons a quarter a coach
that's willing to step out of the box
and get comfortable being uncomfortable
and turn it over to him and he got rid
of a Pro Bowl quarterback to turn it
over to the guy who started one game so
I love this and you're right the
environment around you the creation of
the players around you and what you're
willing to do with them in Buffalo we
wouldn't be talking he wouldn't be the
MVP at the midway point I can tell you
that but we'd be saying potential and I
could tell you this Dan you know when
you go into a movie theater and they say
put your 3d glasses on
that's mahomes man you need to put on
three
glasses when you watch him he is not a
system quarterback he's an all System
quarterback and he's got the guts of a
daytime burglar and I just love the way
he plays and we're in for something
special with the young quarterbacks in
this league and he's at the top of that
list did you play against Lawrence
Taylor I did you did yes yes I'm old
damn cuz that would be your point
well no we were talking I didn't need to
ask that right but but I I was talking
to you know the dance that when I
covered the Giants and I'm watching this
defense and I'm watching Lawrence Taylor
to be on the field to to watch him as
opposed to TV like he's he's one of
those guys where you watch and you go
that there's nobody like him like that's
something he just changed football
there's certain guys were going to say
he changed football and Lawrence Taylor
was one of those guys and I know that
Belichick was asked about Commack and
somebody said could you could you
compare Khalil Mac Lawrence Taylor you
know Belichick Mac's a great player that
they both play football okay yeah Dan we
played against him and think about my
team in the wonder Minnesota didn't go
to more Super Bowls they had me on their
roster but we have Randall McDaniel and
Gary Zimmerman both in the Hall of Fame
on our left side and there are certain
guys you mentioned Lawrence Taylor and
Randy Moss was the same on the offensive
end where they literally you urinated
down your leg when you had to play
against them and Lawrence was one of
those guys that you just you'd go into a
game plan he'd use up so much time of
your preparation because if he would've
lined up in the parking lot during that
game they'd wait I had to go out to
block it you know what I said so he was
special in Gary Zimmerman we'd have you
know you get that guy on the team those
guys who always give linemen a hard time
and Zim was so good and they'd say hey
Zim you know he's coming to town this
week we got LT we got LT and even get
the great Gary Zimmerman ìdo beads of
sweat rolling down his forehead and
Lawrence Taylor was just that cat and
you said no matter what he's gonna show
up he was he was one of those guys you
look at you didn't want to look him in
the eye say I'm just kind of look away
you know like a dog does when it's get
in trouble I think I'll turn my teeth
I'm not gonna stare at that dude so yeah
he was he was he was special I'm sure
DB's felt that same way when they had to
line up again
moss on a regular basis he's the
longtime Red Sox fan Shaun Salisbury
good to have you back on the show John
thank you thank you next time would you
call me back if the Astros or it I don't
have it I'm sure if the Dodgers come
back and take you know three in a row
here you're gonna have Dodger gear on
you have Davey Lopes Jersey on Salisbury
we had some fun times
he he he could have some fun first team
all road trip right there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]